we understand though that these horror
fans were just waiting for
a fight scene that yeah you know a lot
of people want to see michael myers and
jason fight
so
tell us a lot of pressure i guess i had
to do that
um they do fight in this film they fight
a couple times
and
it's an even match you know it's
you're not really sure who's going to
win because first of all derek mears
has a couple things going for him that
tyler doesn't in the in the
story i'm not gonna say what but
it's a tough one you know he's a real
tough villain and
yeah i will say that the fights are
you know tyler and derek both did a lot
of the choreography on that because
they're both you know
tyler used to be a wrestler derek is
does a lot of his own stunts
and they're both comfortable with the
movement and all that so i let them kind
of go at it and figure out what they
wanted to do
that was one of the initial ways that
they got derek on board was tyler was
like hey do you want to fight me and
derek was like absolutely and then
tyler's like no but like in a movie
and he was like oh no well you said yes
already you said yes already so they you
know they agreed to do it and
yeah it was uh it was pretty cool to
film that you know it's two giant guys
they're both like six six
you know fighting each other and
slamming each other around on cars and
kicking each other on the ground and
stuff like that it's pretty wild
how long are those fight scenes and how
long did it take to film them
um
i don't really know exactly how long the
fight scenes are at total in the film
but there's quite a quite a bit of
fighting especially at the end
and
it took a while to film it
we filmed the last day we filmed like
almost the whole day is just the fight
scenes
and we had to still do some pickups to
make that work because we just ran out
of time a couple things but
it all come together pretty well and
yeah you know it's a pretty
pretty heavy part of the film
a lot of action a lot of uh
intense
um suspense there
who's going to win
so it's you know
i have to see the movie i guess to see
who wins
you